[Music]
so we used to think of the middle class
as a seeds category it was 40 hour work
weeks pensions people worked in to her
teachers professors lawyers even and now
it's a shaky er category and that's why
I called it the middle precariat as in
precarious the now it to be middle class
you might not have be able to have a
summer holiday you might not be able to
own your home you certainly wouldn't
have two cars what interests me is also
we had this idea of the middle class
that's a solid thing and now it's a
shaky thing we also had this idea you
move the twentieth century of it as a
humdrum boring thing that we wanted to
escape kind of like Revolutionary Road
Richard Yates and and now it's like
everyone just wants to get into it into
the dream the American Dream of the
middle class that's now and now so
unstable right so one of the things that
that happened was unions weekend it used
to be that 30% of employees were in
unions in the 60s and now it's 7% in the
private sector and that's a that's a
pretty huge drop-off and and at the same
time you're seeing a lot of work
workforce become Giga fied or turn into
freelance contingent etc not stable not
with health care not with the promise of
security and long term employment
there's other reasons why the middle
class has has been under siege one is
the concentration of wealth you see the
rise were the 1% the rise of the
wealthiest since 1997 the income of the
top 1% has grown 20 times the rest of us
they're an ownership class so they tend
to own many of the corporations that are
say creating uber uber economy are
hiring people to drive part-time or the
companies where which which employ
people at hours which means they which
mean that they can't take care of their
children you know hours of the middle of
the night or odd hours in the early
morning and as I write about that in my
book so that kind of wealth
concentration it also it like empowers
people to have multiple addresses and to
not really invest in their neighborhoods
the fact
they're able to pay so much more than
the rest of us for houses and apartments
raises the rents and the cost of
homeownership astronomically in
fashionable cities another one was 1% TV
to describe people who including myself
who watched shows like billions or
Downton Abbey or even madman that sort
of extol the wealthiest kind of
ethically challenged wealthy people so
there's something about 1% television
that I find pretty harmful in that we
are asked to identify and we do identify
with the very richest in this country
rather than middle-class people or
struggling people and that does show our
ethical problems in in it kind of klieg
lights as it were and I think one of the
things that 1% television does is it
makes a case for the deserving ultra
rich like these are people who are
brilliant or talented like a show like
Empire with a hip-hop low goal they
could have terrible terrible values but
they work hard and they have some kind
of genius so they deserve to have this
excess and this wealth and be drinking
champagne out of flutes a lot of reality
television shows work on the same
principle of course what exactly the
they're doing that makes them deserving
is always questionable but the shows are
making an argument that yes they are the
deserving ultra rich and in fact our
president I think was is a it's a very
much a product of 1% television if we
think about The Apprentice which I think
started in 2004 and that was sort of
venerating this kind of empty wealth and
harsh you know edicts to employees
you're you're fired and that that in
itself was the beginning I think of kind
of venerating that wealth without any
criticism on reality television so my
book is very much about a divided
society where so we're just not in touch
with one another and one of the drivers
of that is something I don't really
write about but I work on in my
organization I run called the economic
hardship reporting project and that's
facial inequality which is that people
in cities and in rural areas and all
kinds of places are very divided from
each other by
that it's very stratified and so you're
very unlikely now to run into people
from different walks of life in in big
cities you're far more you're far less
likely than you were in the past I'm
optimistic in certain ways because I've
started having conversations with people
partially around the book about
self-blame about them saying to
themselves you know what's wrong with me
and feeling stigmatized and I feel like
if this book achieves anything or these
conversations achieve anything it's d
shaming people scrambling to stay in the
middle class saying it's not your fault
this is happening to other people you
know the job numbers may look like
they're up but first of all you know
that they often speak to how many jobs
people are having multiple jobs which is
not a great state of affairs for a lot
of people people now have more jobs more
each person has more jobs than they did
in 2016 like individuals so but it's up
by two percent or something like that so
you know it's substantial and that's the
but you can be looking at these job
announcements and you could be thinking
what's wrong with me why can't I figure
it out why can't I get that second or
third gig but the point is why did why
should we have to have all these side
hustles you know why should we have to
have second acts when were 42 and so I'm
optimistic that I'm optimistic that the
conversations people can have can start
to bring about self-awareness solidarity
a better sense of themselves and if I
already heard from people saying you
know I read your book and it said no
stigma and I told my husband when he
couldn't get his second assignment you
know as a freelancer his second job not
his first know stigma and to me that is
that could be just at least it's a vago
mere evolution which as I write like a
kind of emotional mini revolution where
people talk more honestly about their
situation
[Music]